all right uh get ready to invest in Joe
Biden's radical green agenda whether or
not you like it or not uh the
president's very first veto blocking a
bill that would have protected 401ks
from a woke agenda and stop retirement
plan Managers from considering things
like climate change when they make
investment decisions instead of profit
Biden claims it's all about the Maga
Republicans it's their fault
I just signed this veto because the
legislation passed by the Congress when
put at risk the retirement Savings of
individuals across the country they
couldn't take into consideration
Investments that wouldn't be impacted by
climate impacted by overpaying
Executives and that's why I decided to
veto it makes sense to be doing does he
have a grandchild sleeping next door why
is he Whispering is someone golfing and
playing through and while we're on the
subject of climate change looks like
Liberals are moving the goal post again
on doomsday a U.N panel says that the
world has less than a decade to stop
catastrophic warming all right but wait
Al Gore and John Kerry already told us
we should be toast by now
there is a 75 chance
that the entire North polarized cap
during summer during some of the summer
months could be completely ice-free
within the next five to seven years you
have sea ice which is melting at a rate
that the Arctic Ocean now increasingly
is exposed in five years scientists
predict we will have the first ice-free
Arctic summer
okay how'd that go all right so I guess
uh the president feels good about his
veto uh Dana Perino should he feel good
about it because his left wing must be
loving it because he's rest as a green
president didn't matter that mansion and
tester both voted with Republicans on
this now this was a
was it bipartisan
wanted to see
applicants and Democrats work together
they did work together they decided that
ESG was not what they wanted so it's a
bipartisan issue that he went against
and also how does this square with what
the president did last week when he
approved the willow project
in Alaska that doesn't quite square and
besides the consequences of going too
too green too fast are obvious in Europe
since the war in Ukraine what's happened
they've had to figure out a way to beg
barlin Steele in order to get
traditional energy resources because
they didn't have enough so it shouldn't
that be a warning to us that we should
know that and when you know when you
talk about Medicare for all say
everybody want Medicare for all 90 of
people say yes but you say oh it's going
to cost you X Y and Z to get it they're
like actually I don't want that that's
the same with this ESG if you hear oh
it's for environment and social justice
and governance you're like oh that
sounds really good oh but did you know
that it's going to increase the cost of
your food oh oh no I'm not for that so
that's what these legislators are doing
across the states and now they try to do
it in Congress and then Biden vetoed it
so uh so Jesse this is a little
disappointing but not surprising not
surprising he had to do it because he
needs the left but think about how much
help the green agenda needs you need
subsidies you need loan guarantees look
at Tesla you need corporate welfare you
need tax rebates look at the inflation
reduction act that was a trillion
dollars for the green new deal right and
not only that you need child labor you
need the Chinese market and then you
need wind and then you need solar you
need sun all of this stuff goes to
propping up the green New Deal and it's
still not as profitable as traditional
energy so what does Biden do Biden
basically creates a government rule that
tells these investment managers hey guys
you might need to steer the pensions
over here into the green stuff because
again they're not as profitable as
everything else so if you're a teacher
and you have a pension and the
government's invested go here and you
say you know what you're not going to
get a 10 return you're going to get a
five percent return but you're going to
feel a lot better about it you know
Jessica as people look at their uh do
their taxes and look at what they how
much they lost last year a lot of people
say you know what I don't feel as good
about maybe my uh my green agenda and
the investment maybe I got to be a
little bit more Machiavellian when it
comes to what I invest in do you feel
that way that the green agenda has
should have been isolated this was a
chance for the president to escape
to what went on so I read the president
Sherry should be able to consider any
factor that maximizes Financial returns
for retirees across the country that's
should be non-controversial that's
common sense and that does feel like
Common Sense he's not forcing people
into ESG Ventures which by the way if we
return to last week Jesse when we talked
about it
Financial Scions like Steve schwarzman
are very into ESG investing has made a
pillar of what goes on at Blackstone
remember and you said I'm going to go
with Steve Schwartzman on this and it's
on tape it's on mobile Exxon Mobil gets
a great rating for ESG and there are
fossil fuel company so go figure fun but
President Biden took back he said I
won't draw on public lands and then
people said actually you need to be able
to do that and so he did it and he did
the willow project it's going to create
2500 jobs and this is a person who is
using common sense about this and to say
if you you need to show proof that
people's retirements are being wiped out
because of investing in climate projects
yes but there's no proof of that yet
he's just saying let Financial managers
do their job if they see a good
investment in something that's related
to the environment or social justice big
whoop but make people money off of it we
Silicon Valley bank took a bath because
they went green that's not true and that
talking point has basically disappeared
because now we've seen that there's a
huge problem across the entire banking
sector and it's not because they had
someone who made a tick tock video on
their board no they had a lot of work
Investments yeah that's that's the whole
point of this this is all about woke
policy and people insisting that they
should be able to get involved in woke
policy that's what Joe Biden wants he
wants green energy he wants to work with
China so we get all of our lithium
batteries from China and China can start
all these cold producing plants to
create the lithium and that what we
should be able to do is do everything we
can so that they can make money somebody
is making money at the end of this right
and my concern is that it's not the
American investor but the amazing part
of this is that you've got them saying
look the world is coming to an end and
therefore we need to invest because
we're going to die everybody threatens
it the latest is Greta unberg she's
something genius we're all still here
AOC weren't we supposed to be gone in a
couple years I mean what about the
drought in California
this is fear that they're creating and
somebody's making money off it right
okay when we were self-sufficient and
let me tell you I got to add one more
thing the Navy secretary as the Biden
Administration is proposing shrinkling
the the the submarine Fleet level the
the by the Navy secretary says look my
fighting climate change is a top
priority for the Navy are you kidding me
he should be fired but that's their all
woke crazy it's not so can I just said
we should end the way we started
Republicans have not made your argument
Republicans have not said okay you want
to do things green responsible but let
me tell you where we get the rare earth
from let me tell you who we're going to
be dependent on let me just tell you
about the oil and gas company said oh
the back part of this country was going
to happen to them if they die in the
vine we're going to buy them from other
people instead of producing our own
I was one Google assignment or a
research assignment maybe Jessica too
just kidding but the Wall Street Journal
had this big piece last week and it was
called ESG profitable the numbers don't
lie benchmarks analytics and it
basically shows that they strongly
underperform
so there you go but that's the Wall
Street Journal I'm giving my 401k to
Dana Perino oh don't do that don't do
that I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now